[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in today's video we're going to
be discussing lord voldemort
and his horcruxes more specifically
we're going to be discussing his
choice of horcruxes actually one in
particular
nagini a horcrux is an object in which a
dark witch or wizard
has imbued part of their soul and the
ultimate goal when creating horcruxes
is to achieve immortality it's certainly
not well-known magic
and that's because it's excessively evil
perhaps the most sinister aspect of
creating
horcrux is that in order to produce one
you must
murder someone other than herpo the foul
voldemort is the only known wizard to
have produced a horcrux
the only difference there is that herpa
only made one
and voldemort made numerous a diary a
ring
a locket a cup a diadem a boy albeit
unintentional and a snake these were
voldemort's horcruxes
the one that i want to focus on in
today's video however
is nagini from as far back as we can
remember nakini is glued to voldemort's
side
a trustworthy and loyal companion
through seemingly any kind of adversity
they first met in the forests of albania
sometime in the 1980s
when voldemort was weak and just a
shadow of the powerful wizard he once
was
he was lost and unsure of his next move
but it just so happened that so was
nagini
a maledictus that had permanently
assumed her animal form
there were a couple of lost souls a
recently defeated and disembodied dark
wizard
and a lonely snake suffering from a
crippling blood curse
provided that voldemort could actually
communicate with her via parcel tongue
and that voldemort's bloodline had a
connection with snakes it's not
surprising that the pair would couple up
however voldemort's next move was in my
eyes
questionable the move in question was of
course turning nagini
into his final horcrux in 1994 ministry
employee bertha jawkins
made the unfortunate decision to take a
trip to albania i say unfortunate
because at the same point in time
voldemort peter pettigrew and nagini
were all there as well
pettigrew who previously knew dawkins
convinced her to take a stroll with him
into the woods
leading her to voldemort at this point
voldemort tortured and eventually
murdered bertha
as we know in order to create a horcrux
murder is necessary
so in killing bertha voldemort
effectively turned nagini
into his final horcrux ok so nakini was
made to be a horcrux
but why you might be wondering now was
this such a bad decision
here's the thing horcruxes are objects
in which a wizard has imbued
part of their soul the main issue with
turning nagini into one
is that she is a living sentient being
the lifespan of her own
if voldemort's goal was to be immortal
and the goal of creating horcruxes is to
extend your lifespan
then what's the point of having a
horcrux with a time limit on it
even if a maledictus lives for a long
time they are still going to die
eventually so voldemort's decision to
turn the guinea into one
was fundamentally flawed dumbledore
actually discusses the risks of using a
living thing as a horcrux in the book
i don't think so said dumbledore i think
i know what the sixth horcrux is
i wonder what you will say when i
confess that i've been curious for a
while
about the behavior of the snake nagini
the snake
said harry startled you can use animals
as horcruxes
well it is inadvisable to do so said
dumbledore
because to confide a part of your soul
to something that can think and move for
itself
it's obviously a very risky business
however if my calculations are correct
voldemort was still at least one horcrux
short of his goal of 6
when he entered your parents house with
the intention of killing you
he seems to have reserved the process of
making horcruxes
for particularly significant deaths you
would certainly have been that
he believed that in killing you he was
destroying the danger the prophecy had
outlined
he believed he was making himself
invincible i'm sure that he was
intending to make his final horcrux
without death
as we know he failed after an interval
of some years
however he used nagini to kill an old
muggle man
and it might have occurred to him to
turn her into his last horcrux she
underlines the southern connection
which enhances lord voldemort's mystique
i think he is perhaps as fond of her
as he can be of anything he certainly
likes to keep her close
and he seems to have an unusual amount
of control over her even for a parcel
mouth
even dumbledore recognized the dangers
of making a living thing a horcrux
so i'm sure voldemort knew what he was
getting himself into
this is why i think the turning nagini
into a horcrux
was an emotionally driven decision not a
logical one
nagini became instrumental in lord
voldemort's survival before he could be
restored to his real body
her venom kept him alive and it was even
used in voldemort's rudimentary body
potion that gave him a corporeal form
however all of this could have been
achieved without actually making her
horcrux so why here's the thing
voldemort truly deeply cared for nagini
dumbledore said it best i think he is
perhaps as fond of her as he can be
of anything but wait isn't voldemort
incapable of love
yes that's supposedly true but i think
i've found a loophole
first however let's look at the main
canon explanation
for voldemort's supposed inability to
feel love
voldemort's mother marapi was a pure
blood witch and the daughter of marvolo
gaunt
she grew up in little hangleton and it
was there that she developed an
obsession with the muggle that lived
nearby
tom riddle senior voldemort's father one
day
marip decided that she would concoct a
love potion to give to riddle
forcing him to fall in love with her
when he drank the potion he became
infatuated with her
and it wasn't long before merapi was
pregnant with tom's child
after a while however therapy hoping
that tom would genuinely love her
without the potion
stopped giving it to him unsurprisingly
when tom came out of the trance
he simply fled back to little hangleton
abandoning her
after he fled maraby fell into a deep
depression
and stopped using magic entirely on new
year's eve in 1926
she went to an orphanage and gave birth
to her son tom
marvolo riddle lord voldemort tragically
murapi died shortly after riddle was
born
the result of a broken heart maraby's
death meant that she was never there for
tom
and he grew up without any concept or
notion of love
not only that but it has been expressed
that voldemort may have been
fundamentally
incapable of feeling love a lasting
effect of the love potion
that merapee had used on his father an
inability to love was ultimately
voldemort's downfall
it was also what set him off on his path
of villainy thanks to his mother and
father
voldemort was in a way destined for evil
okay so if he couldn't feel love how
could he have loved nagini
well in an interview jk rowling actually
somewhat opens up the possibility
that voldemort could feel love it just
seems like it would be very difficult
for him
how much does the fact that voldemort
was conceived under a love potion
have to do with his inability to
understand love
is it more symbolic it was a symbolic
way of showing that he came from a
loveless union
but of course everything would have
changed if meribe had survived
and raised him herself and loved him in
just a few sentences here
jk rowling opens up the possibility of
voldemort loving something
someone she said it herself if murabi
was there to raise him
then he could have loved that means that
he was never
emotionally incapable as other canon
suggests
so did voldemort ever grow to love
anyone certainly
nakini the pair met each other when they
had nothing
without voldemort nagini would have had
no purpose in the world
no one to talk to without nakini
voldemort would have had a harder time
coming back into power
but it would have happened eventually so
he didn't really need her
he just wanted her around the bottom
line is
he never had to make her a horcrux as i
mentioned earlier
it was an emotionally driven choice a
decision that i believe was made
out of love the pair shared such a
special connection
that he wanted to make it permanent of
course this is just a theory
and i'm eager to hear what you guys have
to say on this topic do you guys
like this theory hate it let me know in
the comment section
below until next time alas
beer wax
you